un des mac s'apprête à fouler des années
mythiques du golfe il participera
dimanche au concours top classe la
semaine du tournoi des maîtres en jour j
il a dû passer par trois étapes de
qualifications pour y arriver et
seulement 10 golfeurs de son âge sont
invités quand je mangeais nerveux parce
que il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
regardera à la télé et j'ai vraiment un
goût de le gagner c'est pour ça il aura
seulement 6 élan pour prouver sa valeur
de coup départ de coude approche et deux
coups roulés
c'est d'ailleurs sur les verts qui
laissait mettre le plus redoutable
qu'est ce qui fait penser qu'il peut
gagner parce que j'ai vu du score final
dans la dernière ronde
j'ai vu que j'ai fini deuxième en tout
dans tout les points donc je pense que
je suis capable de gagner un des mcs a
découvert le golf à trois ans avec son
père en regardant la télé aujourd'hui
même s'il pèse à peine 40 kg ils
frappent déjà des coups de départ de 200
verges
son pointage moyen et sous les 80 et
souvent mieux que celui de son père
je commence à le battre pour essayer
quand même pas faire et je préfère
réaction quand on se bat tous pour la
première fois je sais votre rôle à fond
ce qui était très content ça allait être
réservé la fin compte ça passait à 10
ans c'est la vie en dix matches ne fait
pas que jouer au golf à 11 ans il parle
quatre langues joue du piano et chante
il joue aussi au hockey au tennis on se
gare et au tennis de table
autre chose j'aime pêcher beaucoup parce
qu'il s'affranchit de la patience je te
refais temps pour les jeux vidéo non
j'aime pas ça je dors pas cette vidéo
pas de jouer depuis l'âge de 5 ans
en fait je la nettoie sa race puis
voulait plus acheter des jouets
s'intéressent vraiment combien d'autres
il voit grand il est mon jour est un
golfeur professionnel comme son idole
tiger woods qu'il espère croiser à
augusta il s'est entraîné hier et du
canada brossard